data is your business it's essential for
delivering value to your customers and
outpacing your competitors but as data
growth accelerates and with 80% of new
data being unstructured finding a way to
store distribute and manage all your
data is a big challenge when on site
solutions can't keep up you miss out on
digital innovations and opportunities
with a better data storage solution you
can empower your entire organization IBM
Cloud object storage combines cloud
scalability low cost durability data
security and high availability in the
IBM cloud IBM Cloud object storage makes
it easy to store manage and access data
use the IBM cloud console to choose the
location where you want your data stored
create a bucket and begin storing data
in IBM Cloud object storage store as
much data as you want and retrieve it
from anywhere in the internet with no
minimum fees or setup costs pricing is
simple and flexible just pay for what
you use IBM Cloud object storage
supports s3 api's for an easy connection
between your storage buckets and
applications and SDKs are available for
faster application development when
choosing a location to store your data
you can select IP MS regional service to
store your data in multiple data centers
within a single geographic region or
select frost region service to store
your data in multiple data centers
across multiple geographic regions both
provide high data durability and
availability regional service offers
lower latency and with our cross region
service your data remains protected even
in the event of a catastrophic regional
outage without downtime or intervention
required integration with IBM Identity
and Access Manager empowers you to
securely authenticate users and manage
data access using role based policies
data in motion is secured with SSL
encrypted endpoints well data at rest is
secured by IBM or by using your own
encryption keys select the right storage
class to match your data storage and
access needs and to effectively manage
storage costs choose standard for active
workloads vault for less active
workloads cold vault for cold workloads
and for less predictable workloads
choose smart tier designed for any
workload but ideal for unknown and
changing data patterns smart tier offers
a simplified pricing structure helping
to ensure you receive the optimal
storage rate each month smarts here
works by tracking monthly data activity
and then automatically classifies the
data you have stored into one of three
built in pricing tiers on cool and cold
based on that data activity each month
you'll be billed accordingly at the hot
cool or cold rate across your data
stored in smart tier so by simply
storing your data in smart tier you'll
be automatically billed at the optimal
storage rate each month and for long
term data retention you can set policies
to automatically move data from any
storage class to the low-cost archive
depending on your timeline budget
location and available bandwidth IBM has
the right hardware and software options
to move your data to the cloud quickly
securely and cost-effectively
[Music]
IBM cloud object storage is fully
integrated with IBM cloud services for
building and operating cloud native
applications and making it easier to
take advantage of Watson analytics and
AI services IBM Cloud object storage
helps you get the most out of your data
by making sure it's stored securely is
available when needed scales with your
data and is tightly integrated with IBM
cloud services
helping your business be more agile get
to market faster and deliver compelling
customer experiences get started today
with our free Lite plan for more
information visit our website and sign
up for an IBM cloud account